aquí en guadalupe como prácticamente en
todos los territorios de ultramar marie
le pen ha ganado ampliamente la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
un voto de inconformismo incluso de
rabia para algunos
estoy muy decepcionada en ultramar hemos
votado a marine lepén sin excepción así
que macrón no eres bienvenido excepto
el poder adquisitivo ha disminuido y no
nos da ninguna respuesta así que es
normal que la población reaccione
emanuel macrón no ha sabido ganarse al
electorado de muchos territorios y
departamentos de ultramar y ha aprendido
una lección los electores votaron de
forma muy distinta en cada vuelta en la
primera el izquierdistas jean-luc
mélenchon encabezó ampliamente los
resultados obtuvo más del 56% de los
votos en guadalupe 53 por ciento en
martinica y más del 50% en guyana sin
embargo este domingo fue marín de penn
quien ganó consiguió casi el 70 por
ciento de los sufragios en guadalupe y
más del 60% en martinica y en guyana
también es destacable la alta más del
50% de los inscritos no fueron a las
urnas en la mayoría de estos territorios
pero cómo explicar los resultados por un
lado el costo de la vida y el poder
adquisitivo tema central en el programa
tanto del epen como de milán son en las
antillas francesas el precio de la
alimentación es de media del 30 al 50
por ciento más elevado que en francia
metropolitana mientras que casi la mitad
de la población vive bajo el umbral de
la pobreza una situación asfixiante en
el origen de un contexto social
inestable en noviembre de 2021 la
instauración de la obligatoriedad de
vacunación prendió la mecha de una
profunda crisis social en guadalupe y
martinica la crisis duró varios meses
antes de apaciguarse sin embargo el
malestar es profundo la desconfianza
frente al estado en las antillas es
antigua un ejemplo claro el escándalo de
la flor de kona un insecticida altamente
tóxico usado hasta 1993 en las
plantaciones de banano responsable de
graves soluciones de los suelos y
sospechoso de ser un potente cancerígeno
la inacción del estado en este asunto
como en varios otros alimenta un vasto
resentimiento material en las urnas